vous intéressez au cinéma vous allez
être impressionné par la distribution
réunie pour la nouvelle version de
l'homme au masque de fer inspiré bien
sûr du célèbre roman d'alexandre dumas
accrochez vous avec cette distribution
gérard depardieu
jérémy iron ce également john malkovich
et gabriel barnes dans le rôle des
mousquetaires et puis leonardo dicaprio
qui vient de triompher dans roméo
juliette dans le rôle du roi
nicole cornu l'endroit et bernard puis
se sont rencontrés ces stars à
l'occasion du tournage entre deux scènes
de tournage garde des mousquetaires blé
la bastille reconstitué dans les studios
d'arpajon repos pour les cinq stars
réunies pour l'homme au masque de fer
personnage joué par leonardo dicaprio
qui est en même temps son frère le roi
soleil telles que alexandre dumas
l'avait imaginé dans son roman adapté
très librement par randall wallace et
être prête je joue le rôle de deux
frères qui sont complètement différents
j'ai donc beaucoup de travail à faire
ils ont les rides antique mais je dois
leur donner des caractéristiques et des
très différents pour en faire des
personnalités à part entière la vie
fille mais ça me plaît
les quatre mousquetaires ont pris de
l'âge il se prépare à protéger et à
sauver l'homme au masque de fer
gérard depardieu est pour tous un bon
vivant c'est un homme qui est assez
triste de vieillir mais il est triste
une minute quoi il a un coût de lui
pendant une minute
et puis après il repart de plus belle
c'est à toi sympathique pour tous deux
acteurs américains plus sérieux font
bande à part
l'un et aramis est un homme avec un
grand goût on peut dire ça en grand goût
pour ravir vos réactions paul excitement
pour l'aspect quitte pour la dieu pour
tous je vois un muscle et john malkovich
comment doit-il son atos très secret une
course cette histoire ça mon fils meurt
alors on lit dans un état de profonde
malgré tout les mousquetaires ont gardé
intact leur vitalité mais le plus
fringant est sans conteste d'artagnan
les quatre sont ensemble tout le temps
mais d'artagnan est amoureux de la reine
donc moi je ne peux tu te mets pas les
autres un scénario qui révélera quelques
surprises derrière les murs de ses
studios un nouveau mystère entoure
l'homme au masque de fer
tu vois